hey youtubers it's Charlie since Captain
America Winter Soldier is getting ready
to premiere I thought it'd be fun to
talk about possible stories that could
use for Captain America 3 they haven't
officially announced a release date yet
but they have hired the directors from
Captain America Winter Soldier on to
develop the project there's been so much
other big Marvel news this week
including all that guardians of the
galaxy footage so if you missed it I'm
basically bookmarking Tuesdays is like a
permanent Marvel day from now on I don't
totally know what I'm gonna do next
Tuesday but be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a lot of fun so
anything they do for Captain America 3
will have to tie in with the other phase
3 movies are doing like Ant Man Thor 3
Avengers 3 but here the top 5 Captain
America comic book stories that I think
they could use number 5 dimension Z it's
more of a science fiction based story
that involves this alternate dimension
plot that's a little bizarre but Kevin
Feige said that phase 3 is all about
magic and that opens the door to the
multiverse a big part of the story is
Captain America raising arnim zola's son
as his own and being possessed by Zola
for a little while - the multiverse
aspect of the story they could totally
use red skulls daughter sin or Zola son
in a new movie Marvel even based one of
their major comic book events fear
itself on red skulls daughter sin number
4 operation rebirth Captain America is
forced to work with the Red Skull in the
comic he has to work with the Red Skull
to defeat Hitler his consciousness was
trapped in the Cosmic Cube or you know
tesseract as it's called in the movies
so based on the events of the first
Captain America movie they probably had
to swap Hitler for Red Skull in the
movie and then swap Red Skull for
another villain like Arnim Zola there
are a lot of rumors that Red Skull is
going to be in Winter Soldier but
pending that we still don't know what
happened to him after he got sucked into
the tesseract in the first movie so that
character is still alive until proven
otherwise so he's got to come back at
some point number three crossbones anson
Captain America vs the red skulls
daughter this story is all about how
crossbones you know who's played by
frank grillo in Winter Soldier tracks
down the red skulls daughter sin and the
to wreak havoc for Captain America this
is a big rumor that Emily VanCamp is
secretly playing sin in the Winter
Soldier movie but using that sin
character would give the third movie a
way to bring Red Skull back full circle
plus we're already gonna see crossbones
in Winter Soldier so we've already seen
most of the characters and this story in
movies already number two
the death of Captain America this would
have to be tweaked just a little because
it heavily involves Iron Man and Robert
Downey jr. only has a
tract to appear in Avengers two and
three right now so using him again would
be extremely expensive but they could
substitute that character for another
hero
it was the climax of the Civil War
storyline and it would be a good story
for Chris Evans to leave the franchise
on based on what happens to the
character at the end of the story but
since Evans is signed on for at least
three or four more movies he'll be here
for a long time so it's unlikely they'll
use that story as soon as phase 3 maybe
much later though and my number one pick
for a news story Captain America reborn
this involves the resolution of the
death of Captain America story and the
Sharon Carter character since she's been
played by Emily VanCamp in the Winter
Soldier movie we might get a few teases
from these storylines but reborn is all
about him coming back from the dead with
this supernatural Red Skull body
possession plot it's a very magical /
metaphysical storyline so it would fit
with the tone of phase 3 you know that
magic tone maybe after a Doctor Strange
movie happens and one last bonus option
Avengers under siege this is all about
Baron Zemo and the Masters of evil
storming The Avengers mansion and
beating everyone within an inch of their
life they crushed cap spirit by
destroying all of his world war ii
mementos from before he got the Super
Soldier Serum so it's just villains
twisting the knife in his wounds you'd
have to substitute some of the Avengers
for other characters but Winter Soldier
is already playing with this theme a
little as the villains injure Nick Fury
pretty badly in the movie so there are a
bunch of other possibilities for them to
pick from for Captain America 3 but
remember all of Marvel's phase 3 movies
somatically have to blend well with the
idea of magic and tie into the idea of
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline for
Avengers 3 purposes seriously just
picture Captain America in outer space
the real trick with any Captain America
3 story they do is integrating the more
cosmic elements of the Marvel Universe
into the more practical elements of
Captain America stories but now it's
your turn let me know which story do you
want to see them do for Captain America
3 and do you think that the Red Skull is
going to show up in Winter Soldier so
like I said earlier I haven't quite
decided what my next Marvel movie video
is gonna be on Tuesday maybe guardians
of the galaxy related again be sure to
subscribe to get it
feel free to leave me any suggestions
for anything you want to see in that
right now click here to get a breakdown
of the guardians of the galaxy
characters and
here to get a break down to the Captain
America Winter Soldier trailer thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you